[Música]
hola
le voy a proponer
una cosa re difícil muy difíciles
es tan difícil que te van a tener que
escuchar su corazón
vamos a ver una cosa que nunca hacemos
no
para esto le propongo un ejercicio que
van a tener que cerrar los ojos
así que sabemos los ojos
y cada uno de ustedes
sienta cuáles son sus sueños en la vida
ahora los pueden abrir
los sueños aparecen enseguida
y esta es una pregunta se le dice a un
grupo de chicos entre 6 y 12 años
y me sorprendí
me sorprendí porque uno piensa muchas
veces que los sueños son cosas
materiales que manda decir que quería
tener una ferrari una pelota de fútbol
pero no
lo que mucho me dijieron era que querían
estar con alguna persona que había
fallecido un ser querido
otros dijeron que querían conocer a su
papá a su mamá
entre ellos hay una nenita que tiene 6
años que yo la considero un ser especial
que se llama alma
ya con su nombre ya te hice un montón de
cosas y yo quería escuchar entre ese
grupo de chicos que me iba a decir a
hermano
hasta que llegue a alma que le toca
responder
entonces yo la miro se me mira tiene
todo solito los ojos bien brilloso
marrones y me dice yo quiero ser
millonaria
a diges
hizo esa pausa dice así si yo quiero ser
millonaria para hacer un comedor para la
gente pobre
era especial como yo pensaba no
otros querían ser futbolistas quieren
ser porque están sus sueños otros
quieren ser bomberos policías
y es lo contrario de lo que uno piensa
muy pocas veces les preguntamos a la
gente más grande que nosotros cuáles son
sus sueños y nos olvidamos
a ser una chica me decía el sueño de su
abuela era conocer el mar
al paso por ejemplo un día le pregunté a
mi mamá cuál era su sueño
y se me dijo a mí me gustaría pegarle
una pelotita de golf
y estamos en una ciudad
que tenemos hasta la cancha que al
frente
pero será una cosa
no le ayude a cumplir el sueño
a veces pensamos más en las personas
generalmente que queremos que son
eternas que van a estar siempre al lado
nuestro
pero no es así
entonces como son tan importantes
nuestros propios sueños también son
importantes los sueños los demás
y cuando uno ayuda al otro a cumplir un
sueño
primero se ayuda a uno mismo
cuando una persona seca en la calle yo
voy a ir ayuda a levantarse
primero me siento bien yo
después por supuesto se va a sentir bien
la persona que lo ayude a levantarse y
con los sueños sucede lo mismo
con los sueños mucha gente nos ayudó de
nosotros para realizar nuestros propios
sueños el universo se compagine nos
ayuda el 12-1 nunca se tiene que olvidar
de eso de que hemos sido ayudados y
tenemos que ayudar a otros
y nunca nos debemos olvidar de las
personas que no han ayudado en la vida
siempre tenemos que conservar la
humildad hay sueños que ocurren son
sencillos y hay sueños que son más
llevan su tiempo para realizarse
son los sueños que a veces uno los
empieza a plantearse como un objetivo en
la vida
cuando uno se plantea esos sueños
tiene que poner mucho amor mucha fe
esperanza sacrificio no nos hemos
olvidado hay sueños que duran años hasta
que los podamos concretar
pero para eso
necesitamos de mucho sacrificio mucho
esfuerzo
como quien dice no existe ni lo sabe ni
los domingos ni los feriados
y hay sueños que a veces se traban
nos venimos esos que son llevan su
tiempo los venimos concretando los
venimos concretando de golpe y quedan
paralizados
y me paso con un sueño eso y que no
sabía para dónde ir venía que creciendo
creciendo el sueño
y de golpe
ahí había quedado
y decidirme un monasterio
me fui tres día un monasterio
somos una stereo que uno no puede hablar
tiene que andar en silencio
y cuando iba caminando una mañana que
recién se levantaba la neblina
son monasterios de galerías anchas con
las arcadas y que va entrando el sol
y de frente venía un monje
el monje me mira y me pregunta que lo
que me estaba sucediendo
entonces le digo que tenía un sueño que
venía compre lográndolo y de golpe había
quedado quieto
era un sueño con un fin noble entonces
no entendía por qué ese sueño no se
podía concretar
cuándo
el monje me mira y me dice
lo que sucede es que a veces el hombre
no está maduro
el hombre y entonces me dice ahí
usted sabe y sé cuándo está el hombre
maduro no le di mucho
el hombre está maduro el hombre como
hombre y se dividen en la cabeza en el
corazón y en los genitales yo objeto con
la mano porque me iba pegando
entonces
el hombre cuando saca de la cabeza hacia
afuera
o de lo genital hacia afuera y no pasa
por el corazón el hombre no está maduro
el hombre madura cuando pasa todo desde
la cabeza al corazón y de los genitales
al corazón ahí es cuando el hombre
empieza a madurar
eso me sirvió para después yo volver y
empezar a pasar las cosas por el corazón
y empecé a madurar todavía sigo
madurando y tendré que seguir madurando
hasta el día que me muera
pero me ayudó a que empieza a madurar y
es que los objetivos empiezan a cumplir
ese sueño no hay sueños que uno mientras
que se va cumpliendo ese sueño otros
sueños se van cumpliendo solo que ni
cuenta nos damos de golpe decimos
mira yo que soñaba con no sé
estar al lado de alguien y de golpe
estoy sentado al lado de él
y ocurrió ocurrió porque el universo
hizo que tenía que ocurrir nada más
y hay sueños en los sueños cuando son
que llevan mucho tiempo también tenemos
muchas adversidades que son los miedos
también
y los esos miedos hay que superarlos
el miedo siempre tenemos que superarlo
no nos tenemos que ese miedo no nos
paralice
entonces nunca dejen de soñar siempre
agradezcan a la vida
y así pasó que hace un año atrás en
ecuador había un viejito un nene
y él visitó le contaba al nene
quien las san nicolás se habían
realizado las charlas ted
entonces nene le pregunto el dígito que
era
le contó el viejito nene y le preguntó
si le gustaría
ir a la próxima que es la que estamos
hoy acá
entonces el viejito como iban a tardar
mucho tiempo y se bueno vamos
no te voy a llevar tomaron un burro
en benito se subió arriba del burro
habían puestos los cólicos en ellos las
matas
y empezaron a caminar por el ecuador el
viejito al lado del burro
y toda la gente de ecuador decía
por es perderme arriba el burro y el
viejito caminando y eso iban escuchando
eso que iba diciendo la gente cuando
llegaron a perú
lo que escuchamos cambiar es yo voy
arriba del burro vos vas caminando el
costado
y toda la gente en perú a medida que
iban avanzando
y van diciendo
snell y caminando y el viejito arriba el
burro
hasta que llegaron a bolivia como venían
escuchando esto llegaron agua a libia y
decidieron subirse lodo arriba del burro
a medida que iban pasando por bolivia
toda la gente en bolivia decía
pobre burro
y llegan a la argentina
al escuchar todo eso es más vamos a
caminar una vez
lodo entrando a la argentina y en todos
los medida que van pasando por la
argentina
toda la gente diciendo teniendo un burro
y los dos caminando
y esto que nos dice hagamos lo que
hagamos en la vida siempre vamos a
criticado los importantes de hacer
cumplan sus sueños muchas gracias
[Aplausos]